[Music]
the migration phenomenon is quite
huge here in kenya there are many people
moving from the rural areas
to the urban areas and a lot of these
people
are young and why are they moving
they're looking for better employment
and education opportunities but we
forget that
as more people move from the rural areas
we are putting more pressure in the
urban areas
so that's why we see that there's a lot
of informal settlements that are coming
up
but also we have a rather large informal
economy
meaning that they're not going to access
the decent jobs
so they access more precarious jobs and
that's why we're saying that through
this project
we are trying to address the advanced
drivers of migration
through local value chain development
that means
how can we provide better and more
improved
employment opportunities and
entrepreneurship opportunities in the
rural areas
through agribusiness
cambodia is a hot band for migration
because first of all the proximity to
nairobi
that is the capital city where people
perceive that there are
many job opportunities here but then we
also have to encourage them to stay
within the rural areas because
kenya means farmers are there at the end
of the day the the
the farmers that we have are a quiet
engine and we need a future bunch
that can be able to carry on the angry
culture to fill this nation
the youth believe that maybe farming is
not for them this is what they have
seen their parents doing from thai
memorial and they want to do something
different
agriculture has been linked to poverty
and business for the
people who have not gone to school but
then we see that our youth are quite
educated
and they want the the what they call
them decent jobs
because to them farming is not a job so
they are going to the capital to look
for employment
so what we're doing in this project is
we're trying to to help the youth they
play their role in the angry business so
that we can create opportunities for
them
first of all is to train the men to
empower them say
that in angry culture so there is that
then business they can still make a lot
of money
through the the angry business they
don't have to go to towns
to look for jobs that are not there in
the first place
what we've seen is that agriculture was
considered not
cool or fashionable that is what the
mindset has always been but we are
seeing a new crop
of youth who are taking up agriculture
those who have known what the secret is
many of them who are graduates who have
gone to schools gotten their
their degrees and having seen the
benefits that have come
out of it and not only agriculture but
we're talking about
agri-business bringing in the business
perspective
into agriculture
[Music]
these are the mothers these are my seeds
first of all going to breed them
it's four months old now you're doing
well
at the end if i have a hundred plus
others
then i start marketing them
[Music]
one of the beneficiaries we support is
youth a
unique young lady who studied
for a job in the hotel industry but
following three years in the industry
she decided to
resign from her job and get into
agribusiness
she is currently undertaking a poultry
project
which she got support from the fao and
county
government and this is a lady who is
quite ambitious
she sees herself as the next millionaire
having a whole range of chicken and been
able to supply
the major hotels and supermarkets in
kenya
so for me that is a story that has stood
out a young person
who could easily have worked in a white
collar job but has opted
or her choice of work or business is in
the agriculture
sector
there's no need of going to other
countries you have seen some youth going
to even to dubai catch out to look for
jobs
then they come back frustrated at the
end
they're like oh i wish i stayed in my
country this is our home
god drops kenya we can do it the market
is with us
wake up and go for it whatever is in
your mind you perceive it and
later on you receive it
plural to urban migration is very common
especially
with the youth that is because of lack
of
employment but right now i have come to
london agriculture
has the potential to create many jobs
because currently in africa we still
have
an opportunity to come up with business
agree businesses
which can sustain our economy and
improve our life
as a county we have been trying to make
angry business cool so that we can
attract more youth
and one of the things that we are doing
is to introduce technology
and when we bring technologies within
the sector like the
the mechanization part like the value
addition then they are now interested
then they can be able to come in
and again now we are also trying to
change the mindset that they don't have
to be farmers
they couldn't be transporters they can
get into the value addition
they can be the marketers they can be
there the input suppliers
now we see a change a change of
perception
and we see now the youth the young
people are they are really proud to be
farmers yeah especially now that they
realize
in cambo county there's so much
opportunities for us being close to
nairobi there's a lot of market
and there are opportunities that are
coming in now the youth are
more outgoing they are now going back to
the farm to make the money
the girl the purpose you know that's why
you find me having this
feeding them like my babies you know you
must laugh whatever you're doing
once you change the mindset and and you
know you love whatever you're doing
you achieve a lot
having visited our youth over the past
few days
i would say we have changed a lot
a few years back even when we were
starting this project in itself
many of them were quite skeptical
but having gone through the trainings
having been supported to
to have linkages with the market and
even to access
finance we're seeing them open up their
eyes
and their minds to the opportunities
that are out there
but one thing that we have really seen
stand out
for us is that many of these youth are
people who've gone to school
who could easily have gone to look for a
white collar job
and many who have wanted to migrate to
the urban areas and also internationally
to look for some of this employment and
education opportunities
but many of them have chosen to stay
back home
in the rural economy and see how they
can build their agri businesses
and the key message that i pass out to
youth when we are out there
is that it does not only have to be
production there are very many
opportunities that are in the
agriculture sector and in
agribusiness because
the future is there as we're the future
leaders we're the zero hunger generation
and of course we have our population
gradually increasing over the next few
years
with the food demands also growing
therefore it is important that
youth are brought on board and engaged
in the sector
to be able to produce for future
[Music]
generations